[Music]  eight news now is your local election  headquarters and a senate committee  heard testimony today both  citing and debunking evidence of  widespread voter fraud  nevada senator jackie rosen is on that  committee and said our election was fair  and secure  both our republican secretary of state  and our democratic attorney general have  stated there is no  evidence of widespread voter fraud  occurred in nevada and our highest court  has said the same and i will not  give this false narrative about my state  any more attention than it has already  unfortunately received  our i-team has looked into allegations  of fraud and found two cases of a  deceased voter having a ballot cast in  their name  in total five people voted twice all of  the allegations were forwarded to the  secretary of state's office